welcome everyone and thanks for joining
us for today's webinar integrating in
vitro micro tissues and in vivo
endpoints in drug discovery and
development presented by dr. matthew
wagner associate director of mechanistic
and investigative toxicology at Takeda
Pharmaceuticals
I'm dr. Susie Valdes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that today's presentation is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation just simply click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen and type your
questions into the box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email and
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box and let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits just click
on the continuing education credits tab
located on the top right hand corner of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credit credits
without further ado let me introduce our
presenter dr. Wagner welcome sir thank
you very much Susie and I'm excited to
talk to you today about one of my
favorite topics about the idea of
integrating in vitro micro tissues and
other in vitro assays into in vivo
endpoints in both drug discovery and
development so first off some
disclaimers Peyton Manning I am NOT so
no part of this talk is a paid or unpaid
endorsement for or criticism of anyone's
technology or medicine these are my
personal opinions and not the opinions
of Takeda Pharmaceuticals or any of our
collaborators the second disclaimer is
that I do work for a pharmaceutical
company I've worked for them in the past
I worked for one now and I hope to
remain gainfully employed at a
pharmaceutical company until my son's
pitching arm is strong enough to simple
me financially that's my son Tristan
right there and since he still wears
high heels on his hands it might be a
while until his contract comes in
so those disclaimers out of the way I
let's just look at a very brief outline
I'd like to talk just a little bit about
the promise and potential of 3d Micro
tissues because those are not always one
in the same thing a little bit of the
challenges and opportunities of using
advanced cell culture systems such as
micro tissues as hazard identification
tools and lastly I would like to look at
the emerging potential application of
neural micro issues in drug discovery
screening no surprise to anyone in the
field that micro tissue research which
is called organ on technologies tissue
chip technology spheroid zorga noids
i conflate all of those things into one
big happy term micro tissue here this
field is rapidly expanding it's been
expanding exponentially for about the
last 15 to 20 years or so without
showing any signs of stopping anytime
soon and in fact in the last year we've
seen some really exciting advance has
come out in fact out of me ret surrett
and Linda Griffith lab at MIT they were
able to show in 2019 that they could
keep 10 micro physiological systems not
only alive and functioning but
intertwined and interconnected for over
28 days and so the potential of these
things is understandably thought to be
phenomenal but I think that when US
scientists read those sorts of
publications that I had in the last
slide there's some sort of there's at
some point something's lost in the
translation well that makes it until a
press because from our excitement for
these micro tissues in the academic
setting somehow gets translated into
this idea that it could be the end of
all human testing and you know clinical
trials on a dish and completely
replacing all all animal testing and I
think that there are a few steps to go
before we get there although I am by my
nature incredibly excited every time I
see a new in vitro micro physiological
system when I hear that it's going to
end all animal tests
I do get a little skeptical so I'd like
to give you a little bit of context
about what both why I'm excited and and
why I'm a little bit skeptical that
these things might be the be-all and
end-all and total animal replacement in
the years ahead so there are many many
different practical applications of
micro tissues and drug discovery and
development they can help us translate
preclinical toxicity that we see in a
mouse a rat a dog or a monkey and and
they help to understand how that
toxicity in an animal may actually
translate to humans and and perhaps even
more usefully we can use them for early
hazard identification these are
sometimes called predictive assays but I
think hazard ID is a more accurate term
it we can use them to help understand
which molecules in a really early stage
may cause toxicity far down the line
they can be used as clinical biomarkers
that can be used themselves as
regenerative medicine tools and I think
the idea that we can use them for total
animal replacement is a very laudable
goal and it's an important goal and it's
one that we should keep striving for but
it's one that we have a lot of progress
to make before we get there and so what
I'd like to focus on today are what I
consider to be practical intermediate
steps between where we are now and in
what total animal replacement looks like
in the future so this slide is taken
from a a relatively recent paper in
Nature Reviews drug discovery where
they're looking at really what's causing
drugs to fail in development and and
what you can see of really cherry-picks
just one of the figures here and if you
look at the red stars you can see that
39 percent of all development compounds
failed in GLP talks here looking at a
snapshot of four different
pharmaceutical companies pipelines over
about a 10-year period and about eleven
percent of those compounds failed in the
clinic due to clinical safety so all in
we had over 50% of late-stage attrition
was being driven by either toxicity or
safety concerns which is really why we
get so excited about all these different
organs and and tissue dips and in degree
micro physiological systems like we have
pictured there but the the scope of the
challenge I think is a lot bigger than
some people realize so if you look at
what's recommended by the Society for
toxicological pathology STP they reckon
they recommend over 40 different tissues
be taken on a GLP TOC study and examined
by a board-certified pathologist in
order to make sure from two different
species in order to make sure that drug
is safe in us enough to progress into
humans so even if we did have you know
the best heart on a chip or brain on a
chip available you know the likelihood
that we will one day have 40 separate
and interactive chips for adrenal glands
in aortas and bone and brain and cecum
all tied together I think that that's
it's it's a ways from where we are today
and I think it helpful to maybe focus on
more intermediate goals like focusing on
a single species tox package or what
I'll be focusing on today just trying to
put our best molecules forward and a
great safety by design into our drug
discovery pipeline and and trying to
make the best of the animal data that we
have so maybe we don't have 40 tissue
chips and micro tissues that we can use
to predict toxicity but what if we just
focus on those primary drivers for
attrition so this is from a 2014 Nature
Reviews drug discovery paper looking at
the AstraZeneca pipeline and these are
all the various toxicities that caused
attrition due to toxicity or safety
either in the preclinical space the red
bars or the clinical space in the brown
bars and and what you can see here is
that really you can capture just about
80% of all safety-related attrition if
you focus just on eight organ systems
and though maybe an intermediate
question could be in an ideal world
would we want to have a predictive micro
tissue for each organ well and I think
that that answer that question we have
to recognize that toxicology has
something of a unique challenge to it so
false positives
affect us in toxicology very differently
from the way they affect our friends in
the pharmacology realm so efficacious
false positives so if you're in vitro
assay tells you that your new drug is
going to cure cancer well you will
figure out that false positive that that
was a false positive when you move into
your first or second or third in vivo
model and then you'll be able to swap
out a better molecule with something
else that worked in vitro that will
hopefully then work in vivo before you
make it at the clinic but toxicity false
positives are very different very often
those red flags that get stapled to our
molecules damage that molecule and cause
it to be discarded and so really what we
want to focus on when we're looking at
hazard identification and what are
sometimes called predictive assays we
really want to focus on specificity
making sure that we don't have any of
those type 1 errors false positives
aberrantly calling the molecule
potentially toxic and let me tell you
why if we try to have a perfect micro
tissue system for just those eight
different organ systems that drive 80
percent of the safety related attrition
and AstraZeneca portfolio we saw a few
slides ago and let's say that you had a
pretty good assay that had say 70
percent specificity well if you put
every single molecule that your chemists
had made let's say you just had a
fictional pool of 1000 molecules and you
put them through a different predictive
micro tissues with 70 percent
specificity well then you could expect
94 percent of your 1000 molecules to be
discarded as false positives and even if
you have an incredibly specific in vitro
assay 90 percent specificity or your 8
different micro tissues and you ran them
serially well then you could expect to
throw away over half of your portfolio
on false positives alone you've
discarded over half of your chemistry
and not made a single person safer so
you can see why using these hazard
identification assays for every single
micro tissue might be problematic so we
do have to be just a little bit picky
about the way that we
employee and employee that is so I think
that well the way that makes the most
sense and is perhaps intuitive to
everyone is that we want to try and
focus on those primary drivers for
safety related attrition and and amongst
those primary drivers perhaps another
more famous or more common than
cardiovascular toxicity and with in
cardiovascular toxicity the cardiac of
post-approval adverse event reports are
dominated by pro over the present Pro
rythme events over the last 20 years and
so what we're looking at and I'm sorry
the videos didn't come through here is
is the way that we can use IPS derived
cardiomyocytes and here the paper that
we're citing is just looking at a 2d
syncytium of cardiac micro tissues and
we're looking at is the the idea that
these 2d cardiomyocytes actually do a
fantastic job of predicting Pro
arrhythmia in this case with
procainamide but it's not enough for us
that it have a couple positive controls
sorry that's light apparently isn't
going to come through it's not enough
for us to just have a couple of positive
controls like I was saying before we
really have to be quite certain of any
of the data that we generate with a
hazard identification assay because if
we if we run every single molecule in
our portfolio through some sort of
Hazard ID assay we need to be highly
certain that this assay is highly
specific and we won't be throwing the
baby out with the bathwater and so this
is work that was done by Emily Fleischer
Pfeiffer Kaushik in my lab while she was
at Valles sciences and what she showed
was that in a validation in this case of
over 90 compounds all of which had
clinical exposure and adverse event
information is that this to decent
syncytium of IP derived cardiomyocytes
actually does a fantastic job of
predicting that QT prolongation which is
directly related to Pro arrhythmia and
actually it compares quite favorably
with other assay systems that are
currently out there and being widely
used like non rodent ex vivo assays like
the
and so if we look at the sensitivity and
specificity of these iPS derived
cardiomyocytes in this kinetic imaging
cytometry assay you can see that this
assay and this validation set was 80%
sensitive in over 98% specific which was
vastly outperforming one review article
that was looking at Lang in north and
other xbo essays where they reported it
as having only 33% sensitivity and 80%
specificity so that 18% gap in
specificity is massive because those are
all compounds that would be thrown out
with no safety or or enriching benefit
and so when you have an assay that has
just 2% false positive rates that means
that when you're talking to your project
team and your project chemists and you
come back with a positive in your in
vitro assay you can say with high
confidence 98% of the time this is
something that would have caused is
likely to cause QT prolongation in the
clinic this is a high-risk molecule and
so if we just play out the numbers on
that for a minute
and I swear I just use big round numbers
and these are all ballpark estimates so
forgive me I'm not a mathematician so if
we have 1,000 compounds that 2015 paper
we saw from Pfizer and Astra Zeneca
showed that okay we can expect for
roughly 500 of those to be lost due to
safety related nutrition and so if we
look at the relative proportions about
12 and a half percent I'm sorry about 25
percent of safety related nutrition can
be attributed to cardiovascular toxicity
and if we look at this IPS derived
cardio myocyte assays as being one that
has 80% sensitivity and 98% specificity
well then we could expect in a pool of
1000 molecules to throw out 10 compounds
as false positives from that pool of 500
safe molecules and we would throw out
102 true positives and retain only 23
toxic molecules in our in our pool of
1000 molecules so what that gives us
that is that gives us a pool of
molecules that has been over fivefold in
the rich
for non cardiovascular toxic molecules
so you're throwing out 10 true positives
for every false positives that is a
really good benefit because your your
your screening against the high
frequency toxicity with a high
specificity assay but just because you
have a high specificity assay doesn't
mean that you should be using trying to
develop an assay with that highest
ethnicity for every single toxicity
Under the Sun what if we had a toxicity
that was a lot less common like
phospholipid OSIS and let's pretend that
we have an assay that is every bit as
good as the IPS derived cardiomyocytes
are at predicting Pro arrhythmia well
and we ran it on that same pool of 1000
compounds but with a much less frequent
toxicity something that's present oh and
about only nine out of every 1000
molecules that would come out of them an
average pharmaceutical company's
portfolio well we could expect to throw
out the same ten false positives that we
threw out with our last assay but out of
the but we could except expect to throw
out seven true positives and and leave
two toxic molecules behind so what that
means is that in order to throw out
seven true positives we had to throw out
ten false positives so there's no net
enrichment for safer chemistry there and
and this is the problem with trying to
stack too many predictive assays on top
of each other and that's why we tend not
to call these predictive assays they're
just hazard identification and we use
them to try to understand and prioritize
molecules in the really early chemistry
space and the lead generation lead
optimization space trying to choose
chemical series and and novel small
molecules to move forward then into into
mini tox or exploratory toc studies onto
a little more complex 3d tissue system
this was some outstanding work that came
out of Astra Zeneca and Janet X lab that
was led by well Proctor and Dominic
Williams and and here this is work that
was done looking at a spherical human
liver micro tissues for the
prediction of clinical drug-induced
liver injury now
these human liver micro tissues their
self-assembled spheroids made of pooled
primary hepatocytes from ten different
donors with non parenchymal cells
including cook for cells and liver
sinusoidal endothelial cells all wrapped
up into that one happy little spheroid
now the benefits of this 3d culture
system is that compared to 2d primary
hepatocytes these 3d tissues have
greater drug metabolic capabilities
cytochrome p450s we're much longer lived
they have better albumin production more
physiologically relevant bile acid
handling including the transporter level
a more robust mitochondrial function and
they do have some semblance of an innate
immune response because you do have cook
for cells in there and here again they
have a fantastic in vitro validation
data set and what I like about this data
set in particular that I wanted to
highlight here is that they're directly
comparing the 3d assay the exact same
hepatocytes plated in 3d which are the
black dots there and comparing it versus
the 2d which are in the white dots for
each individual compound which you see
in columns and we're looking at the
cytotoxicity ic50 along the y axis so
what you can see here is that these are
I think oh is 60-ish or so compound 69 I
believe compounds that that are all
known to have drug-induced liver injury
in the clinic and what you can see is
that these 3d liver micro tissues have a
significant number of they are much more
sensitive to drug-induced liver injury
in vitro when they're plated in 3d the
black dots then they are an 2d versus
the white dots and this isn't trivial I
think this is something that is not
often dumb it's not often enough
demonstrated these 3d assays come they
come they bring along with them a much
higher opportunity and compound and
consumable cost and though we need to
prove to ourselves in to our management
that these 3d tissues are
worth the added time and cost burden
what was nice about this data set is
they also had a very robust number of
true negatives and so these are
compounds that are in daily severity
categories four to five and what they
showed here is that you had the exact
same number of true of false positives
and in the 2d as well as the 3d assay
and they looked at they did a very
robust job characterizing these 2d and
3d systems and what they showed is that
they had identical specificity at at
this optimal cutoff of 100 micromolar
here and the 3d micro tissues had almost
double the sensitivity of their duty
counterparts and so this helps us in a
number of different ways it helps to
establish assay performance criteria
it helps us establish cut-offs based on
risk tolerance for somebody's drug
discovery portfolio and it helps to
provide appropriate context of use you
can figure out which mechanisms of
toxicity in this in vitro assay does a
good job of picking up versus a bad job
of picking up and and we won't go too
much into that today but one of the
things I really wanted to highlight here
is that I think a lot of people focus on
the very robust validation of these in
vitro micro tissues that are going on
but not often enough do I see it
compared against the validation sets
that have been performed for our in vivo
species so our predictive in vivo models
the rat the dog the non-human primate
were looked at in a beautiful
publication from monticello at all out
of the IQ consortium and and they looked
at a wide number of things in terms of
the productivity of our preclinical
species for clinical endpoints and they
looked at 182 compounds that had
completed their phase 1 trials and for
which they had a complete GLP tox
package and then they looked at the
concordance of of adverse events
observed in the phase 1 trial versus
what was observed in the rat dog and
non-human primate so I don't want to
encourage us to make direct comparisons
between the in vitro validation set on
the left for the liver
my current issues looking at 110
compounds and the invivo set at the
right they're looking at 182 compounds
but I do think that we can look at these
things side by side and begin to
understand how these two in vitro and in
vivo they're not warring with each other
but they do help us do very different
things you know these in vitro assays
are fantastic hazard ID tools and so
looking at the strong suits for for this
in vitro system and this published data
set you can see that the positive
predictive value in this 180 110
compound set is pretty good it's 88% and
so these in vitro deliver micro tissues
show promise for early hazard
identification with strong specificity
and positive predictive value and that
same positive predictive value is
something that might be kind of a weak
spot for the rats or dogs if you look at
the monticello paper on the right
instead where these in vivo systems are
so important is if those in vitro
systems are great at hazard
identification the in vivo systems are
much better at risk assessment so one
thing that we don't often do with our in
vitro assays is try to establish some
sort of a an individual margin of safety
where we say you need 34 large and
before between your C max and an end of
each row I see 50 I think that if that
if those data are out there to make a
strong case for doing that with cell
based assays then I had not yet seen it
developed and I would love to but at the
moment they seem to be useful hazard
identification tools we have a lot more
experience with a preclinical species
though from the risk assessment
perspective so we can actually use them
to to both identify the the target
stalks organ tissues as well as trying
to measure the risk to humans based on
exposure that was seen pre clinically
and the exposure that's predicted to be
seen clinically and one thing that I
think these in vivo tools are fantastic
at that are in vitro tools you really
don't get a is these in vivo studies
have very strong negative predictive
values so looking focusing here just on
drug-induced liver injury and 182
compounds
you can see that the negative I'm sorry
the specificity of the non-human
primates and especially when you combine
the rodent and non rodent species you
have outstanding 98% specificity so if I
call something a positive it's going to
be a positive and in fact if you have
either species that has called the liver
safe well then that negative predictive
value is pretty fantastic at 92% in this
data set and so a lot of people try to
think of in vitro in vivo in a warring
sense and I don't see it like that at
all I think that we use them for very
different things and this is just one
example of how these these two tools are
not meant to replace each other but
rather complement each other another
perfect example of that as you can see
from this table on the right that the
rodent and non rodent species don't
always agree but those liver micro
tissues on the left they're available in
Ratdog non-human primate and human
versions so we can use these liver Micro
tissues to actually understand and pick
apart mechanistically what might be
driving these species specific liver
toxicities and so I'd like to talk to
you about one more type of a safety
related attrition that's of intense
interest for me of late and that's
really looking at CNS toxicity a CNS
toxicity is a really tricky one it's
incredibly common especially in the
clinic but if you look at this 2014
publication of master's indicate you can
see that far and away the preclinical
toxicity those things you're able to
pick up in vitro and in preclinical
species you only lost seven due to CNS
toxicity in the preclinical space but if
you look in the clinic you had 34
molecules that were lost to due to
clinical CNS toxicity so there's
obviously a very large predictive it
egapp that that isn't unique to Astra
Zeneca that's something that it through
it exists throughout all of Pharma so
why is our CNS attrition so high and is
why is it so tough to predict with our
existing in vitro in vivo tools
well these CNS toxicities are primarily
identified as
clinical and histopathological
observations made on animal models of
CNS function during GOP talk studies
during relatively narrow slices of
tissue and time
and unlike cardiovascular rated related
nutrition there are no mandated electro
graphical telemetry studies to to give
us a reading into what might be
happening at the EEG level for all these
CNS targeting drugs before they make it
to the clinic there are no readily
monitored or validated biomarkers for
toxicity like alt or ast are for liver
or serum creatinine or blood urea
nitrogen or for kidney and there's very
poor productivity of neural structural
and functional toxicity in preclinical
species so there was a fantastic
publication by Andy need when he was
still at Pfizer looking at 141 compounds
and looked at the concordance between
the neuro functional assessments and the
in the Erwin test so it's called and
then the concordance of those
observations in the Phase one clinical
trials namely headache nausea dizziness
fatigue somnolence and pain and they
found that those were not predicted by
the functional observation battery
battery or the Erwin test and so that
begs the question why why is this so
hard to predict what I think that
histopathological II they've done a lot
of work to look at to to examine this so
accredit to Mary Carson a head of global
pathology here at Takeda for getting me
the slide and educating me on the topic
but when it comes to pathology there's
actually a relatively narrow window
within which you can catch this
neurotoxic ology and so this is a
publication by Robert Switzer where he's
looking at just about 10 molecules and
the actual the peak cell death that's
visible under H&E staining days post
administration and what you can see is
after delivering something that we know
to be CNS toxic I believe here in
rodents and what you can see is that the
visible toxicity really peaks in the 2
to 5 day time frame and then after that
those dead or dying cells have been
cleaned up and cleared out so that by
the time you were reading out your GLP
talk study at 14 or 28 days or over
three months or six months there's
nothing more to see and so there's a
dearth of predictive preclinical models
across the industry and I really think
that that's what's driving the high
levels of CNS tox related attrition and
so it's that that was driving us to want
to investigate more these neural micro
tissues now this is a neural micro
Tishri developed by us demonics out in
San Diego and these are cortical
spheroids and they're highly homogenous
in size and competition and composition
they're about five hundred microns in
diameter and they're balanced
composition of both cortical neurons and
astrocytes at a 50/50 ratio those
neurons are a good mix of inhibitory
GABAergic and the excitatory the
glutamatergic neurons at an 8020 ratio
in favor of the glutamatergic the best
of all they're playable in a 384 well
plate format meaning that pharmaceutical
toxicologists like myself can run the
dose response curves and the large-scale
validation sets that we need in order to
understand and validate these assays for
hazard identification so one of the
things that we really like about these
cell types is that not only do they have
some of the not only do these narrow
micro tissues have some of the cells
that we care most about but they have
some of the function that we care most
about and this was something that was
unique to these micro brain tissues and
in fact one of the other mini brains
that we looked at I had hardly any in
vitro calcium dynamic at all but when we
put a calcium-sensitive dye and then
looked under a flipper what you can see
is that these neural micro tissues
actually have a fantastically robust and
repetitive calcium bursting signal and
and we measured six different parameters
within that calcium oscillation looking
at peak amplitude big spacing peak width
peak count along with rise time and
decay time
and what chain Hwang and Collin Choi my
lab did is they looked at combinations
of cell viability after one week as well
as compound induced effects on calcium
Oscillation up to six hours straddled
around the the c-max of over 80
different pharmaceuticals with a known
clinical adverse event and exposure
profiles and sorry this is a beautiful
video that we'll have to show you some
other time but that's not going to play
here today and so and what we found is
that these micro brains really give us a
robust and reproducible measure of a
number of different types of
neurotoxicity and so the video is behind
these beautiful still images were taken
by colin choi my lab and then what he
showed is that when you put on a seizure
ionic molecule like for immuno pyridine
that you can double the number of bursts
that you would see over a 45 second time
period so you've doubled the amount of
neuronal activity with a seizure
orogenic compound so it's obviously
something that's that we would hope
would be indicative of seizure-like
activity in vivo looking at other types
of more neurotoxicity
so here we treated micro brains with
compounds for 30 minutes had
concentration straddle straddling a
clinical c max and we measured the
calcium signal in these these cortical
micro tissues in response to MPTP
challenge MPTP is an interesting
molecule because it itself is not toxic
but it is a little fill a compound
that's known to cross the blood-brain
barrier and once it's in the brain MPTP
is metabolized by the glia into MP p
plus by monoamine oxidase B and the
glial cells MPP plus itself is toxic and
so I'm seeing a relatively short time
window is that this MPTP is being taken
up by these neural micro tissues
metabolized by the glial cells and then
it's directly altering the the number of
Peaks which you can see reflected there
in the peak count as
we're going at higher and higher
concentrations from the left of the
right along the x-axis and so this gives
us some some hope that these neural
microchips may be metabolically
competent and functionally responsive to
neuro degeneration at least in this case
due to MPTP looking at other models of
neurotoxicity so here we're looking at
Kanak acid which is a very commonly used
molecule for kindling and it's very
popular for in vivo models of epilepsy
it's a direct agonist of the glutamic
kn8 receptors and large doses of
concentrated solutions produce immediate
neuronal death by excited excited
toxicity and so what you can see here
within I believe a 30-minute time window
is that increasing concentrations of
Kanak acid create a very rapid loss of
not only peak amplitude but also the
peak count and so again reinforcing the
idea that these micro brains are both
metabolically competent and functionally
responsive to nerve degeneration by
Kanak acid but like I was mentioning at
the beginning we really can't rely on
these small sets to to validate our in
vitro assays we really need to be able
context of usin appropriate cut-offs on
very large validation datasets and so
we're currently running a large
validation dataset ourselves looking at
a number of different mechanisms of
neurotoxicity and then we won't have
time to go into it today but suffice it
to say that with a brief overview here
of the multitude of mechanisms of
neurotoxicity as well as the high level
message of our validation data set down
here is that we're very excited about
this micro brain model and and its
potential moving forward as we and
others helped to validate this model and
really begin to understand its potential
utility as a translational and a hazard
identification tool and with the last
couple of minutes i have before that the
talk is done first of all I have to
fulfill every toxicologists obligation
of having at least one quote from
Paracelsus per presentation so there you
go poison
and everything and no thing is without
poison the dosage makes it either a
poison or a remedy so that's my
contractually obligated request
fulfilled but the reason why I wanted to
focus on that today is because I think
that the age of toxicology as a
standalone discipline is is really
beginning to fade away I think that if
we want to have greater impact both in
discovery and development then we really
need to team up with qsp modelers and
quantitative systems toxicology modelers
so that we can take our mechanistic and
our Hazard identification tools and
really begin to turn them into
translational tools so and I'll give you
one example of the ways that that can be
done so if we were looking at the effect
of say in this case a kinase inhibitor
on bone marrow increasing concentrations
in a in a rat exploratory talk study
with an exploratory molecule caused
maturation arrest and in the erythroid
lineage and and some hypo cellularity in
the bone marrow and and they could send
the pathologist could tell by looking
underneath the microscope that these
common progenitor cells which
differentiate over a period of days and
in reverb lasts and pro ruber sites and
then rubra sites and meta ruger sites
and then reticulocytes and eventually
into mature erythrocytes they could tell
that this process was halting but they
couldn't tell exactly where and and this
is really where the modelers and the in
vitro systems come into play is that so
these findings were in rats but we
couldn't tell exactly which stage this
maturation arrest was occurring in and
we couldn't tell exactly what would
happen in a human because of course a
rat is not a human we understand this on
both an intrinsic level as well as a
quantitative level and it's important to
begin to stitch those things together so
starting with what we can do
quantitatively with that sort of a
maturation and differentiation protocol
well this was this is work that was
really championed by Jay Mehta tall and
hairy Shankara of AstraZeneca and and
what they were showing us was using a
variant of the frybread model you can
actually look at the way that free
compound concentrations
have a direct effect on erythroid
progenitors and then erythroblast sand
reticulocytes immature red blood cells
and and hemoglobin in the circulation
then what's important to note here is
look at these numbers in the transitions
from progenitors to erythro blessed you
can see that rats have a 48-hour
transition time where humans have 83
hours and for mature red blood cells the
the half-life for mature red blood cells
around 100 1400 hours whereas for a
human it's closer to 2,800 hours so if
we try to understand and quantify this
toxicity using rat bone marrows our
model for human toxicity we're really
putting ourselves at a disadvantage both
in terms of the biology because we don't
understand if the potency against rat
differentiation is the same as it is for
human as well as for the the qualitative
aspects of differentiation and so what
many of us in the field have started
doing is beginning to stitch together
the semi mechanistic modeling with this
fry bread type modeling that's more
traditionally used for neutropenia
modeling but here the example is around
anemia and integrating the in vitro
micro physiological systems where we can
run in parallel say a model of human
bone marrow loss and a model of rat bone
marrow loss and we can then determine if
the human is more or less sensitive than
the rat and then overlay that on these
understood quantitative differences in
the differentiation timing and profiles
for these preclinical species and with
that we can begin to give estimates of
clinical safety and begin to make
recommendations to our clinical teams
let's say like listen we we believe that
we may or may not have this risk based
on what we've seen in vitro or in vivo
and if we do have this risk we might
recommend using this sort of a dose and
holiday schedule or this sort of Akko
medication and we can expect these sorts
of patients with high or low hematocrit
levels to to respond adversely and those
are exactly the sorts of graphs that I
think that we need to be generating more
and more moving forward we need to go
from being a semi-quantitative field
into a more quantitative field at least
on the in-vitro side
and and this is just a mock-up of what
some of these sorts of analyses can look
like where you have where you can make
predictions for the hemoglobin loss for
patients that either have a strong
hematocrit or a weak but not quite
anemic hematocrit going into your phase
1 trial and how you might expect that a
compound administration to affect a wide
range of patients over time and begin to
call when you could expect those
patients stabilized when you could
expect them to undergo grade 1 grade 2 a
grade 3 anemia all those sorts of things
so that's that's really it for me I
wanted to thank everyone both Harish and
and J for all the work that they did on
the semi quantitative modeling work as
well as the chin-wagging and Collin choy
and Emily kasha and pH Bajaj for all the
work they've done in our lab here and
Jenny Cohen Yvonne dragon and Bill
Penney here at Takeda and I wanted to
say come join us
we're hiring immunologists and
experience drug discovery biologists at
Takeda right now so please check that
out at Takeda jobs calm and thanks a lot
for your time and attention
have a great day and thank you dr. Ryan
they're quite informative presentation
I'd also like to thank elaborate for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 2019
as a final reminder dr. Waggoner will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
and thank you for joining us we'll see
you next time bye bye